shadow of the Tomb Raider caught my eye
with its unique modular difficulty
you're able to customize not only the
combat but the exploration and puzzles
as well to fit the experience you're
looking for games typically don't adjust
things like platforming and puzzles and
their difficulties so I was intrigued
about how this would affect to the
experience so I've cranked up the
settings to max to see how tough shadows
the Tomb Raider can really get I'm
primarily gonna be talking about the
game's Hard difficulty called one with
the jungle there is a difficulty setting
above it which I'll get to at the end of
the video just know that it's the exact
same thing with one major difference for
added challenge I also turned off
survival instincts which is the game's
version of Batman vision there's also no
option to turn off HUD for that truly
hardcore experience but that's okay as
the game's HUD is already very minimal
and there's no mini-map in the game
period let's start with the combat in
addition to increased health and damage
from enemies help regeneration in combat
is removed ammo boxes are more scarce
the hit marker on the reticle is removed
and enemies are no longer highlighted in
survival instincts something that
doesn't really matter since I turned it
off anyways you'll notice that in the
first half of the game there are far
less combat encounters than previous
Tomb Raider games when you do encounter
enemies the game is almost always
encouraging a stealth playthrough and it
certainly becomes much more necessary on
the hardest difficulty but honestly the
combat is never that demanding enemies
are easy to stealth kill either up
closer with your foe you'll go down
quickly if shot at but it's not hard to
escape line-of-sight and most enemies go
down just as quick as you I highly
recommend trying the game on the hardest
combat setting combats fairly easy on
lower difficulties and hard demands a
lot more from the stealth options which
is where I think the combat really
shines with more becoming a savage
predator by the time combat picks up
significantly in the second half of the
game you should be more than
well-prepared for it next up is
exploration the big difference is the
removal of the white paint that lets you
know what is crumble and where to go
next this is the most unique and
interesting of all the difficulty
settings and I was curious how well this
would actually work because there is a
good reason that white paint exists
games like Tomb Raider uncharted or
basically any game with lots of climbing
use color as an in-game way of directing
the player without it players can get
confused or frustrated ruining the
pacing and flow of gameplay
these games are typically designed with
these markers in mind so to remove it
seems like a recipe for frustration to
my surprise though I didn't encounter
much trouble I had to spend a lot more
time stopping and thinking for a moment
to figure out where to go and there were
those moments of oh hey is that ledge I
can grab him oh no no I guess not but
for the most part it was a smooth
experience it's actually pretty
liberating to navigate without any hints
relying instead on my own instincts of
what I think I can grab last is puzzle
difficulty which removes any hints laura
will give you along with all glowing
markers from survival instincts and I
love this so much complex puzzles have
become a staple of the Tomb Raider
franchise and I've always enjoyed taking
a break for a good brain teaser now
these aren't like final area of portal
levels of challenge but I did get stuck
several times and it's fun to try and
figure it out only thing you have to
watch out for is puzzles where someone
comes over the radio to tell you a clue
that's necessary if you happen to not be
paying attention you might be out of
luck okay Jonah what's the final number
for shock shell thanks
okay so I did mention that there is one
final difficulty setting known as deadly
obsession it's the exact same thing as
one with the jungle but checkpoints are
removed and you can only save at base
camps playing on this mode can be a lot
of fun you want to stick to stealth
exclusively and really think before
every jump
one wrong move or a stray bullet is all
it takes to lose an hour of progress
base camps are plentiful enough that as
long as you plan it out you'll be okay
especially during the hub areas if you
die at any point however during the
hour-long story heavy intro where there
are no base camps then be prepared to do
that all over again I found some
frustration at times towards the
controls in certain platforming sections
where I felt I was jumping one way only
for Lara to jump somewhere else and fall
to her death in on a mode like deadly
obsession
this can be frustrating also I should
warn you if you pick deadly obsession
you can't change the difficulty setting
at all so make sure you're committed to
it if that's what you're gonna do deadly
obsession is doable and really rewarding
but I think it's a better fit for a
second playthrough where you feel more
comfortable with the game
and that shadow of the Tomb Raider on
its hardest difficulties overall I
didn't find it to be as much of a
challenge compared to other games so if
you're a seasoned Tomb Raider player I
highly recommend getting one with the
jungle ago you can always change the
difficulty later if it's too much for
you or if you've found certain aspects
appealing like no puzzle hints but are
interested in removing the white markers
you can always mix and match to your
liking but however you end up playing
the game I hope you have fun
[Music]
you